a toddler is recovering in the hospital
this morning after falling into a rhino
exhibit at a Florida zoo officials say
the girl slipped between a set of steel
poles during an educational experience
and came into contact with the snout of
at least one of those rhinos Manuel
bulwark is is at the Brevard Zoo in
Melbourne that's about an hour outside
Orlando where the incident happened man
well good morning good morning zoo
officials say they've had the Rhino
encounters program for nearly a decade
and have not had an incident like this
now there are questions about exactly
how it happened and what needs to be
done to make sure it doesn't happen
again a toddler was rushed to the
hospital after slipping through these
poles into this Rhino enclosure and
coming face-to-face with one of these
white rhinos according to Florida's
Brevard Zoo the little girl came into
contact with a rhino snout the area just
under the animals horn her father
reportedly jumped in after her her
mother was also taken to the hospital to
be treated for injuries and has been
released a witness post at this picture
shortly after the incident showing what
is believed to be the girl's shoe inside
the exhibit the incident comes just days
after a lion killed a woman at a North
Carolina animal refuge
the person that was attacked how bad are
they hurt 22-year old intern Alexandra
Black was helping clean out the lion's
cage when it escaped a locked area and
attacked her after efforts to
tranquilize the lion failed zoo
officials shot and killed it
oh my god and in 2016 a four year old
boy climbed into a gorilla enclosure at
the Cincinnati Zoo the child survived
but zoo officials shot and killed the
gorilla later they made safety changes
to their exhibit including installing a
higher barrier and surveillance cameras
inside the enclosure officials here at
the zoo say they will suspend the Rhino
encounters until they can review their
safety protocols the Rhino that was
involved was apparently not harmed and
officials say will not be euthanized as
for the little girl her father released
a statement yesterday saying it was a
trying day and they are now focused on
her recovery anthony men well thanks